In the famous Disney film, Pocahontas sang
about the “Colors of the Wind”, and we
learned that everyone can get along, despite
their cultural differences.
While the intent behind the movie may have
been good, it is nowhere near being historically
accurate.
The true story is much darker, and for some
of you out there, this video just may ruin
your childhood memories.
This is the true story of Pocahontas.
A Peaceful Existence
The first thing you should know about Pocahontas
is that it wasn’t her birth name.
Native Americans have a unique tradition when
it comes to someone’s name and identity.
Children are given a name at birth, and it
often changes as the person grows up, and
the family learns more about their personality.
At birth, her name was “Amonute”.
And as as she grew older, she was developing
into a true beauty, so her father gave her
the new name Matoaka, which means “The flower
between two streams”.
She was apart of the The Powhatan tribe of
Eastern Virginia, which had a population of
over 25,000 people.
They were broken up into roughly 30 smaller
tribes, which were governed by respected village
leaders.
Pocahontas’ father, Wahunsenacawh, was the
one head chief who was above all other tribal
leaders, known as the honorable “Chief Powhatan”.
The Powhatan people had a tradition where
one woman from each tribe was sent to become
one of the wives of the Chief Powhatan.
Women came of age at 14 years old, and they
often found a husband soon after.
So it’s likely that they would also be around
this age when they were chosen.
Once the young woman gave birth to his baby
and weaned them, she could leave the child
to be raised by the Chief, and go back to
her home village to get married and started
a family of her own.
While it sounds like a frightening prospect
for the modern world, this was considered
to be a huge honor.
Only the most beautiful and intelligent girls
were chosen to have children with the Chief,
so that they could pass on the best traits
of the tribe together.
These children of the Chief were given special
training, and often grew up to be the next
generation of leaders in their community.
There was one wife who held a special place
in Chief Wahunsenacawh heart.
He gave her the nickname “Pocahontas”,
which means “the playful one”.
When he was raising her daughter, Amonute,
he noticed that the girl’s personality was
almost exactly like her mother.
He started to call her “Pocahontas” as
well, because they were so much alike.
There is no historic record of what happened
to her mother, but most historians believe
that she must have died during childbirth.
As a young girl, Matoaka would run through
the forest, climb trees, and do cartwheels.
She was always laughing and smiling, ready
and willing to play with her dozens of half-siblings.
Her mother’s name truly did suit her, so
at age 14, when she went through her coming-of-age
ceremony, she chose to officially change her
name to Pocahontas.
Colonization, and The Lies of John Smith
In the early 1600’s crews of British explorers
gathered supplies on their ships, and sailed
towards the New World.
Once they arrived, they founded the Jamestown
Colony in 1607.
One of these explorers was a man named John
Smith, who was dubbed the “President of
Virginia” and the “Admiral of New England”.
He would later publish a book bragging about
his adventures, which many modern-day historians
know is full of fiction.
In his book, John Smith claims that soon after
he arrived in Virginia, he was captured by
a man named Opechancanough, and he was tied
up and paraded around all 30 villages.
Then, he was brought to Chief Wahunsenacawh,
who ordered his execution.
Apparently, he accepted his fate with dignity,
but just as his head was about to be smashed
on a rock, a beautiful girl named Pocahontas
comes to his rescue, begging her father for
mercy.
According to him, she said that if he must
kill John Smith, then she should die, too.
He goes on to talk about their newfound friendship.
Kind of sounds like the Disney movie, right?
But most historians agree that this sounds
completely ridiculous, for so many reasons.
First of all, Pocahontas would have only been
9 or 10 years old at the time, and John Smith
was 27.
Children were never allowed to be near anything
as brutal as a trial or execution.
This story also paints the Native Americans
as being savage, and willing to kill anyone
without a valid reason.
The true story is that in 1608, the Jamestown
colonists were starving, because they had
run out of supplies.
Instead of trying to negotiate a fair trade,
John Smith ordered his men to attack the tribal
villages, and steal whatever they could.
He would also set fires, and demanded that
they give in to his demands.
However, the weakened colonists were no match
for the tribe, so many of the white men were
killed or taken prisoner.
John Smith was their leader, and he begged
for the Chief to spare his life.
Chief Powhatan chose to have mercy on John
Smith, without Pocahontas being involved at
all.
Later, John Smith would have spotted the beautiful
little girl playing with her friends.
When he found out that Pocahontas was the
Chief’s favorite daughter, he made a mental
note of it, and filed that away for later.
An Act of War
When she was 14 or 15 years old, Pocahontas
married a young man named Kocoum, who was
the brother of one of the village leaders
known as Japasaw.
She moved to this new place to be with her
husband, and this new village was much closer
to Jamestown than where she grew up.
And the news of this new “princess” moving
into the tribe’s village spread, so even
the colonists knew of Pocahontas’ arrival.
John Smith also remembered from years before
that she was the Chief’s favorite.
In the summertime, the Native Americans would
walk around naked when it got too hot outside.
To them, there was nothing sexual or exploitive
about it- they were all just people trying
to keep cool.
But to the English settlers in Jamestown,
this was shocking.
And considering that many of these were men
who already saw the natives as less-than-human,
and they hadn’t been with a woman in a very
long time...
You can guess what happened.
Women and children were taken from their homes
and violated.
In Powhatan culture, if a man committed sexual
assault, the rapist was immediately sentenced
to death.
As soon as they see that someone is a rapist
or a murderer, they’re gone.
There is no such thing as rehabilitation.
They’re never going to pass on their DNA.
Sorted.
This made the crime extremely rare.
In England, though, men got away with rape
all the time.
Women were often accused of lying, unless
there was a witness- which, of course, there
almost never was.
Even if he was caught, the punishments were
far from a death sentence.
So when the Powhatans people interpreted this
as an act of war, and the Chief Powhatan was
ready to attack Jamestown.
This began the first Anglo-Pawhatan War.
Meanwhile, Pocahontas was now 16 years old,
and heavily pregnant.
The white men in Jamestown devised a plan
that they would kidnap her and use her as
leverage, to stop Chief Powhatan from completely
obliterating the colony.
Pocahontas had just given birth to her first
baby.
She would have been in the care of the tribal
women, and away from her husband, Kocoum.
Soon after delivering her child, a white man
named Captain Samuel Argall snuck into Pocahontas’
tent in the middle of the night, and kidnapped
her.
Physically weak and recovering from giving
birth, Pocahontas didn’t stand a chance
at defending herself.
In his book, John Smith described the scene
of Pocahontas being carried to the English
men’s massive ship.
She had never seen this technology before,
so she was screaming in horror as her abductors
forced her inside.
There was a jail cell in the bottom of Captain
Argall’s boat, which is where they locked
her up.
In his version of the story, John Smith blamed
everything on the Native Americans, of course.
He wrote that the Powhatan had stolen their
weapons and supplies from Jamestown, and they
were using Pocahontas as leverage to broker
a peace treaty.
Even though he writes about her distress,
he never goes into further detail about what
happened to her.
According to the Native American’s oral
history, Pocahontas’ husband, Kocoum heard
the news that she had been kidnapped.
Kocoum galloped towards Jamestown the next
day, killing men with his arrows as he went.
He made it all the way to Captain Argall’s
ship, but he was gunned down before he could
save her.
John Smith wrote that they kept Pocahontas
while they waited for payment from Chief Powhatan.
He says, “We received part of the payment,
and returned (her father) this answer: That
his daughter should be well used; but we could
not believe the rest of our arms were either
lost or stolen from him, and therefore til
he sent them, we would keep his daughter.”
So...Basically, this guy is justifying kidnapping
a teenage girl and blackmailing her father,
and somehow, the English thought this was
totally acceptable when they read it in his
book.
Of course, those weapons never came, because
they had never been stolen in the first place.
Pocahontas eventually fell into a state of
depression.
We know from the Native American oral history
that she stopped eating, because she missed
her family so much.
The colonists needed to keep her alive for
leverage, so her sister was finally allowed
to visit.
When the two young women were allowed to speak,
Pocahontas told her that she was being raped
by the crew of the ship on a regular basis.
She begged to come home, but the English men
were refusing to let her leave, unless her
father promised to give them weapons and supplies,
and sign a peace treaty.
But of course, Chief Wahunsenacawh was never
going to stop the war until he got his daughter
back.
Don’t Worry, it Gets Worse.
Records show that the First Anglo-Powhatan
War lasted from 1610 to 1614, but the timeline
of events gets a bit blurry.
According to John Smith, Pocahontas was only
on the ship for three months.
But if you actually think about it logically,
she must have been kept prisoner on that boat
for at least a year, if not longer.
Some records claim that she was kidnapped
near the beginning of the war, in 1610, while
others say it happened in 1613.
This is also why many history books are fuzzy
about her exact age and date of birth, because
there are so many conflicting stories of exactly
what happened.
What we do know for certain is that during
her time as a prisoner, Pocahontas became
pregnant by one of the men.
Now that there was a child on the way, the
men could no longer hide the fact that she
had been raped in captivity.
It would seem that there was no hope in negotiating
a peace treaty, now.
They needed to come up with a plan to cover
up their crimes.
This is where John Rolfe enters the picture.
He is credited for being the first man to
bring tobacco farming to the Jamestown colony.
He was able to build a sustainable business
for the colonists to make a profit by growing
tobacco and shipping it to England.
Since there was so much land in this New World,
tobacco became a booming business.
So, if you don’t already hate his guts by
the end of this story, you can basically blame
him for bringing bad smoking habits and lung
cancer to the western world.
Rolfe was a widower in his 40’s.
He was friends with all of these men who were
keeping Pocahontas prisoner, and he may have
been one of the rapists.
He offered to take one for the team and marry
her.
The only trouble was that an English person
could not marry a Native American, because
they were considered less-than-human.
In 1914, Pocahontas was forced to go through
a Christian Baptism, because it was the one
and only way they would even consider that
she might have a human soul.
She was Baptised in the Anglican Church, and
given a new name English name; Rebecca.
Shortly after her Baptism, she was forced
marry John Rolfe.
Now that Rolfe and Pocahontas were married,
this sealed the deal.
The colonists claimed that the two had fallen
in love.
Once Chief Wahunsenacawh knew that his daughter
was safe, and apparently happy, the peace
treaty was finally negotiated.
This became known as the “Peace of Pocahontas”,
because from that day onward, the Jamestown
colonists and the Powhatan tribe were finally
able to stop fighting, if only for a few years.
Even though her father had agree to the peace
treaty in hopes to get her back, she was never
allowed to see her family again.
Life in England
Once she was married to John Rolfe, Pocahontas
was forced to begin a new life in England.
The Powhatan people had a tradition of tattooing
their bodies.
Even the women had face tattoos, which has
lead some people to believe that Pocahontas
may have had them, as well.
But since women were so covered up in England
back then, it may have been easy to hide her
ink.
From the perspective of the English people,
this was a wonderful love story.
Two people from vastly different cultures
were able to fall in love in the New World,
where anything can happen.
But of course, not everyone was drinking the
kool aid.
During an interview, someone asked John Rolfe
if he truly loved her.
Normally, if someone asks you to prove your
love for your significant other, maybe you’d
start gushing about all of their wonderful
qualities.
But John Rolfe responded that if he was actually
trying to take advantage of a teenager, he
would have chosen a white girl who was “more
pleasing to the eye”.
Despite all of the glaringly obvious issues
with a 40-something year old man marrying
a 17 year old, this narrative that Pocahontas
was “choosing” a white husband and converting
Christianity was also a sign to white people
that maybe these natives weren’t so savage,
after all.
They became so popular, people wanted to make
souvenirs of their union.
Portraits were even painted and sold of Pocahontas
and John Rolfe.
These happy stories became so popular in English
culture, that their fictional romance was
published in newspapers everywhere, and it
even inspired the Disney movie Pocahontas
2.
John Rolfe claimed that the unborn child was
his, of course.
And when Pocahontas gave birth to a son, who
they named him Thomas Rolfe.
He was also baptised as a Christian.
Legally speaking, John Rolfe was taking on
all of the responsibility as a father.
He signed his name on both their marriage
certificate, as well as Thomas’ birth certificate.
John Rolfe got to enjoy Pocahontas’ newfound
fame and popularity, as she was invited to
the best parties in the country, and became
a household name.
Portraits were commissioned of her wearing
the traditional European clothing, and she
had to learn to speak fluent English.
She was forced to style her hair and makeup
like English women, and completely conform
to their society.
Everyone now called her “Rebecca Rolfe”,
instead of her chosen name.
Despite the fact that she was a young woman
who had been abused and taken from her home,
Pocahontas handled her new duty as a diplomat
with grace.
She was representing the Powhatan people,
and everyone called her the “Indian Princess”.
Pocahontas was incredibly polite to all of
these new English people, and represented
her tribe to the best of her ability.
After meeting Queen Anne and King James, their
view of Native Americans completely changed.
They could see that these people actually
did have souls, and began to push for a more
peaceful coexistence between the colonists
of the New World, and the natives.
A few months after arriving in England, John
Smith finally stopped by for a visit.
By now, Pocahontas had learned of all the
fictional stories he had written about having
a friendship with her to the Queen.
In fact, she had thought John Smith was dead,
after he was arrested for what he had done
to their villages.
She had no idea that he had used her name
to create a fictional universe where her entire
tribe was full of savages, and she was the
one person who had hope of having a soul.
He created a best-selling book based on lies,
stained with the blood of the innocent.
Seething with rage, Pocahontas confronted
John Smith, and told him off for ripping her
away from her family for the sake of his own
glory.
She said, “Your countrymen will lie much.”
Death, and Legacy
As we mentioned earlier, John Rolfe owned
a tobacco farm in Virginia, but he lived in
England, and managed the incoming shipment
of his product.
Rolfe’s ships were going back and forth
to Virginia on a regular basis, and Pocahontas
begged him to let her return home on one of
them.
The better she got at speaking English, the
more dangerous it became for the men who captured
her, and lied about it.
As time went on, it became possible that she
would eventually expose the truth.
So in 1617, when their son was 2 years old,
he finally agreed to bring them back to visit
her family.
Not long after they set sail, Pocahontas contracted
a mysterious illness, and died on the boat.
While there is no record of what killed her,
most assumed that it must have been one of
the many illnesses that the English had built
up an immunity to.
At the time, no one dared to suggest that
it may have been foul play.
When she died, they turned the ship back around,
and returned to England.
Pocahontas was buried in St. George’s Church
in Gravesend.
Rolfe could have afforded to give his wife
the best funeral money could buy, but she
was given a pauper’s burial in an unmarked
grave.
Young Thomas was sick with the same illness
that had killed his mother.
Instead of helping to nurse his son back to
health and help him cope with the trauma of
losing his mother, John Rolfe left him with
some random dude called Sir Lewis Stuckley,
and sailed back to Virginia...Because if we
know anything in modern times, it’s that
leaving kids to live with strange men on their
own has always worked out perfectly fine.
Nope.
Nothing bad has ever come of that.
Thomas made a full recovery, but it was clear
that John Rolfe no longer wanted anything
to do with him.
In his mind, he knew that the boy probably
wasn’t his biological son, anyway, and it
would seem as if he felt no fatherly love
towards him at all.
John’s brother, Henry Rolfe, finally learned
that his nephew was being watched over by
this Lewis Stuckley guy, and he quickly jumped
in to take custody of the boy.
Henry was shocked by his brother’s cold
heartedness and willingness to abandon his
own son with a complete stranger.
Even though John Rolfe was wealthy from tobacco
farming, he refused to give any money to his
brother for child support.
Henry Rolfe actually had to sue John in court,
demanding that his nephew be left with something.
John Rolfe never had any other descendents,
so when he died, Thomas inherited the tobacco
farm in Virginia when he was 20 years old.
This was the first time that Thomas Rolfe
had sailed back to Virginia from England.
Now, he was a wealthy landowner, and he had
to learn about the tobacco farming business.
He also became a lieutenant of the Jamestown
Colony.
Thomas grew up hearing the stories of his
mother, Pocahontas, and he knew that his grandfather,
half-sister, and his many aunts and uncles
would have been overjoyed to see him.
By this time, there had been several wars
and conflicts between the Native Americans
and the colonists.
There were now strict rules that the colonists
should not interact with the Native Americans,
and vice versa.
Thomas Rolfe tried to petition the governor
of Virginia to let him meet his family, but
his request was denied.
He lived among the white colonists of Jamestown.
If he ever found a way to speak to his relatives,
he would have had to do it in secret, and
there would never be a record of it.
Yes, this story was incredibly tragic and
downright infuriating.
We wish there was a happy ending.
Unfortunately, sometimes, the bad guys win.
But if it were not for Pocahontas’ resilience
and strength, this story could have been so
much worse.
She was such a special person, that she was
able to prove to the English that the natives
truly did have souls, and were worthy of maintaining
their culture.
If there is any light in this dark story,
it is that Pocahontas became a well-loved
icon for hundreds of years.
For all of the historic inaccuracies, the
movies inspires a love and understanding of
Native American culture, as well.
Instead of focusing on the darkest parts of
her past, the world has chosen to celebrate
her best qualities- Her friendliness, kindness,
and diplomacy.
She chose to embrace the name she gave herself-
“the playful one”, because at the end
of the day, it’s still who she truly was.
We’re not going to ask if you enjoyed that
one, but feel free to vent your frustrations
in the comments below.
Or, if you’re trying to cheer up after hearing
that story, what Native American style name
would you call yourself?
Thanks for watching.